Today South Park
says goodbye to Mr. Hankey
the longtime union
of this town
and the holiday figure
is over for good.
We should all feel
pretty great about ourselves.
Give ourselves a little
nice pat on the back
as we as a society
continue to try
and sweep away all the poop.
Well everyone I guess
this is goodbye
it sure has been swell.
No goodbyes Hanky you
just need to go.
We've
already called you a puber.
A puber, they have that?
Oh you mean Lyft.
Ok goodby everyone.
I hope I brought a few smiles
and a few laughs
into your hearts.
Goodby Mr. Hankey
Where will he go?
He'll have to find a place
that accepts racist
awful beings like him.
There are still places out there
who don't care
about bigotry and hate.
Hidy ho! Cool man talking crap
Welcome my friend.
Please rest your weary feet
and make yourself at home here.
Hooray!